when you think of your favorite band or
musician what image comes to mind
for a lot of people it's fancy cars
gucci jewelry and a mansion on beverly
hills but
this kind of lifestyle is becoming less
and less common
even for artists on major labels the
media musician makes about
35 000 a year and not all of that comes
from music
a lot of artists need other gigs and
even the ones who can survive solely on
music
are often middle class with less people
buying
music and artists making very little
from streaming
the bulk of a musician's income comes
from playing
live shows but because the covet 19
pandemic is preventing these live shows
from happening
many musicians are more strapped for
cash than ever for most musicians
it's a constant hustle with little
return this is why julia and i decided
not to pursue this career ourselves even
though i love to play guitar and i love
to sing
we just couldn't see how a career in
music would be
financially sustainable but we don't
want to see other musicians throw in the
towel
their music is too important it helps us
enjoy life
feel moved and see things from new
angles so is there something
fans can do to help or is a music career
a thing of the past
[Music]
popular music was more or less invented
in the early 20th century
thanks to two technological innovations
radio which allowed people to discover
new sounds
and the phonograph which allowed
musicians to monetize their songs by
selling copies
though the physical format has changed
over the years
the basic system lasted for most of the
century giving rise to
hundreds of famous artists from nat king
cole to britney spears
and spawning several multi-billion
dollar record labels
this business model was up ended in the
late 90s with the invention of an audio
codec
called the mp3 and a file sharing
program
called napster suddenly songs could be
encoded into very small file sizes and
napster let users share them with each
other for free
all you had to do was search the song or
artist you wanted to hear and you'd be
connected to a user who had that music
for the first time ever listeners had an
entire world of music
at their fingertips it was awesome for
them not so much for the musicians who
felt like their work was being stolen
which well it kind of was the major
record labels weren't so happy about it
either
since napster wasn't paying them
royalties they
came after the company with copyright
lawsuits and one
causing napster to declare bankruptcy in
2002.
but the genie was already out of the
model new file sharing programs popped
up to fill the void left by napster
and though there were legitimate ways to
digitally purchase songs like apple's
new itunes platform
it's really hard to compete with free
the industry struggled to monetize and
music sales plummeted in the 2000s
some economists described this as a
categorical change
psychologically consumers had
categorized music
as something that you didn't pay for
like emails or tortilla chips at a
mexican restaurant
categorical changes are really hard to
reverse once they've taken hold but the
following decade
the music industry figured out how to
get people to pay for music
without feeling like they were paying
for music subscription
streaming services like pandora and
spotify
for a flat monthly fee subscribers can
listen to all the music they want
and the platform pays royalties each
time song is played
these royalties are split between
songwriters publishers record labels
recording artists and managers
talk about a lot of middlemen even
though these royalties make up 80
percent of the music industry's revenue
the musicians themselves tend to make
very little
in 2019 artists earned on average .0043
cents on spotify and .0168 cents on
pandora
other streaming services weren't much
better these rates aren't set in stone
though and vary by
artists that's because streaming
services usually take company earnings
and divide them up based on how many
streams
a particular artist has so if you pay
9.99 a month and only listen to
one obscure indie band in a perfect
world the entire 10 bucks would go
straight
to that band but that's sadly not how it
works
the money is split by every artist and
not
equally either if say billy eilish gets
of all streams on spotify she'll get 10
of your money even though you never
listen to her
the more streams an artist has the
bigger piece of the pie
they get i wish we could say this money
adds up to a pretty hefty paycheck
but that's not usually the case
musicians would need about
87 000 plays a month on pandora to earn
the national minimum wage
and about 336 000 plays on spotify
even if you manage to get millions of
streams it's still not a big payout
so if streaming services aren't
typically lucrative
and you can't go to live shows right now
how do you support your favorite
musicians
thankfully there are lots of ways you
could pull
in 1999 and buy their music artists
signed major record labels often make 10
to 15 off these sales
and indie artists earn even more so if
you buy their album for 10 bucks
they'll make at least a buck but what if
the album is already on a subscription
service you use like spotify
in that case you might consider buying
their merch this could be a t-shirt
hoodie perfume or a doormat
man swifties aren't messing around
artists who run their own merch can take
home most
or all of the money they make from those
sales other artists typically earn
around 30 percent of the merch sale
depending on the deal they have with a
merchandising company
if you'd rather support your favorite
musicians directly
see if they have a patreon which lets
fans pay creators every month in return
for cool rewards like live performances
and unreleased music
some artists are even streaming live on
instagram facebook youtube and twitch
which may allow you to tip them or maybe
they're playing full-blown digital
concerts on stage it where you can buy
tickets
soundcloud even lets you send money
directly through their paypal
venmo or cash app you can also support
musicians through good old-fashioned
word of mouth
post about the band on facebook make
your roommate listen to them
this gives them new listeners who could
turn into fans and supporters plus
the more buzz a band gets the more
likely they'll catch the attention of
filmmakers and advertisers for those
sweet licensing deals
[Music]
however you choose to support musicians
we suggest going beyond streaming
services
these services are a great way to
discover new artists but they're not a
great way to support them
if you really like a band consider
buying their albums or merch or watching
them perform
they get more money that way and the joy
and fulfillment these artists bring to
our lives
is worth paying for and that's our two
cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy
click the link in the description to
become a two cents patron
[Music]
you